hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the pan look
through the pan the plan this is a
experimental little game made by
krillbite Studios which is the same city
as that's making among the sleep which
is a game where you play as a toddler
wandering your house as night that game
is not released yet but I've been
following this one and it was just
released yesterday so I'm gonna give it
a try as you can imagine it involves a
fly I am controlling this fly as I
suspected I actually don't know what the
point of the game is and I'm assuming
that's part of the reason why it's made
you're not supposed to know exactly
what's going on
I seem to be in the forest floor I'm
guessing it just means exploring the
life of a fly from the flies perspective
but I've gone off screen and I can go no
farther I'm looking for down landed up
here got out of here I don't know
exactly what I'm looking for quiet I
have no idea just kind of flying upwards
floating up into the sky Bleich a
magical majestic creature
[Music]
what was that sounded like a car I guess
from a fly's perspective everything
seems foreign and unnatural but either
way maybe my goal is to find some sexy
female fly banger and make some fly
babies ah shot all balls I should have
seen that coming
now you're not gonna give me today
screw you spider get out of here
do you think you are you know who you're
messing with
I'm Isaac Clark in fly form
okay the Mon Depp the most badass fly in
the world is just wandering around and
he's badass because I'm playing him ah
fly
I mean leaf I'm assuming that was gonna
smack me right out of the sky I mean I
love creative attempts at games like
this like an idea that no one else would
imagine to put into a game or a game
form it's just this really really cool
idea of exploring as a fly who would
make a game about that but it's
fantastic that someone does it C's
experiments and this game is totally
free click the link in the description
below you can play for yourself the game
is totally free and just really really
interesting I like it a lot I mean come
on you're a fly that's like that's a
unique perspective that no one has ever
done before it maybe someone has I don't
really know as part of gaming I have yet
to come across a game where you play as
a fly twin kidney so don't know what the
objective is or what I'm looking for
I've just been flying up for upward for
quite a while I mean flies typically are
a bit faster than this but I'm
progressively zooming out
come on run into a chameleon in a tree
or something a lot of things prey on
flies I feel pretty oh so pretty
and I'm flying a little bit drunk
hey stop blowing me I need to go this so
maybe I do maybe I don't I'm not exactly
sure
[Music]
love the music nearing the top of the
trees
[Music]
it seems like a lot of work went into
this game for it to be free very
impressed so far
[Music]
I mean it's games like these that
allowed the player to sort of imagine
his own story I guess since we're not
given any cues we got to make up the
purpose of this game for ourselves so my
guess is it's just an attempt to show
life in a different perspective that's
often forgettin forgotten forgettin
forgotten
ooh those are known as the pillars of
creation there are nebulas there a
nebula of star matter light-years and
light-years away and that's the
Horsehead Nebula and it's like the
entire pillars of creation are hundreds
of light-years in length and light-years
in length and their beautiful thing that
caught by the Hubble telescope and I did
not know that this fly could go into
space
[Music]
[Applause]
man that was awesome
I was like such such a unique concept
and so deep and haha filled with like
meaning that was so cool I mean short
yeah oh my game crashed anyway so anyway
um I think I'm all done here my game is
thoroughly crashed but anyway that was
so cool try it out for yourself maybe
there's some secrets because I'm sure
that there are ways to die and fly
around there like it could have been
killed by the spider or something else
or I guess I couldn't have touched the
big light bulb in the sky but either way
that was really cool and I always liked
unique things about gaming they say
something different about what gaming is
all about and so if you guys want to try
out for yourself the link is in the
description below check it out it's
totally free and heads up for krillbite
Studios game which is among the sleep
which was released a while ago remember
toddler going around tonight so thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the annotation for more video as said
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]